WE CHANTED EARLIER.
- RELAX.
STILL GOT MY ACID,
AND I'M READY
FOR THE ACID LIFE.
LATRO.
[firecrackers popping]
[overlapping chatter]
- UH, WE BETTER
GET GOIN', HUH?
- NO. IT'S FINALLY
KICKIN' IN!
- WHAT DO YOU SEE?
- I SEE A BEAUTIFUL
DANCING ANGEL GOD
WITH FLAMES FLICKERING
FROM HER FINGERTIPS.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
- NO, THAT'S A GUY ON FIRE.
- DAMN IT, I MUST HAVE
GOT A BUM TAB.
THIS SUCKS, DUDE!
- OH, BOY, HE'S CATCHING.
- I'LL SEE YOU NEXT YEAR,
PSYCHO D!
YEAH!
OWW!
- WHOO!
I'M JUST GLAD
THAT I GOT TO STAY
IN A HOTEL FOR ONCE, MAN.
NOW I CAN SAY THAT.
- GOD, I CAN NEVER
SHOW MY FACE
AT THIS CONVENTION AGAIN.
- DERS, JUST DRIVE ME HOME.
I WANT TO FORGET ANY OF THIS
EVER HAPPENED.
[discordant guitar note]
- [high-pitched]
I WISH I WOULD HAVE TRIPPED.
DRIVE ME. DRIVE ME!
- OH, NO, I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA.
NOT RIGHT NOW.
- THIS IS NOT NEGOTIABLE.
RIGHT HERE. DRIVE.
[ominous music]